bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
à quoi ressemblera l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines demain les
grands axes ont été définis à travers le
projet de territoire ce qui demain le
développement économique le
développement environnemental et la
qualité de vie et la mobilité sont parmi
les priorités
comment vont se traduire ces projets
vous faites point c'est parti
[Musique]
depuis l'élargissement du territoire à
12 communes saint quentin en yvelines
construit son projet ce qui demain après
la phase de diagnostic en concertation
avec les habitants et les acteurs locaux
les grands axes se dessine
nous avons déterminé des axes qui sont
des axes prioritaires sur ce projet de
territoire avec un chapeau qui est
l'innovation durable
je crois qu on est tout à fait dans le
sujet actuellement puisque on a bien pu
ressentir auprès de la population cette
montée forte de la biodiversité de la
nature de la protection de la planète et
nous on est en plein dedans
avec en plus le 7 7 a été agrémentée du
mot innovation qui n'est pas un mauvais
au niveau de saint quentin puisque vous
savez que saint quentin en yvelines est
vraiment en tête aujourd'hui d'une
innovation dans beaucoup de domaines à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'innovation
passe par les entreprises automobile
aérospatiale numérique banque et finance
énergie
dix sept mille entreprises se sont
implantées dans l'agglomération une
présence qui permet de comptabiliser 145
mille emplois indiscutablement saint
quentin à soi beaucoup de chance soit en
tout cas beaucoup d'autres activités
parce que on a de très bons résultats en
développement économique et
en plus ça s'améliore on l'a vu
notre gros salon international que l'on
a au mipim
on voit bien mais introduit sur les
engagements des entreprises sur leurs
souhaits sur le fait qu'ils veulent
prendre des locaux ou à s'agrandir ou là
on voit bien que ça se passe très bien
très bien aussi côté entreprises y
compris chez les start up au niveau
développement de l'urbanisme pour les
entreprises trouvent que c'est une niche
eu vraiment pour les entreprises qui est
très très bien par rapport à toutes les
entreprises que l'on voit quand on est
sur la route on se dit qu'effectivement
peut-être caniche assez importante de
d'offres d'emploi j'ai vraiment
découvert un territoire qui facilite le
développement des sociétés qui accueille
les sociétés en son sein et qui fait
vraiment le job de les mettre en
relation grâce aux différents événements
je pense au sky business dell par
exemple à d'autres forums qui sont
réalisés sur le territoire
on a réussi à redistribuer plus de 80%
dans le territoire donc c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est vraiment
particulier à ce territoire parce que
l'on bénéficie effectivement de d'un
nombre colossal de société sous
traitance logiciel conception de cartes
électroniques assemblage d'ensembles
mécaniques
autant d'éléments réalisé jadis à
l'étranger et qui aujourd'hui sont
finalement effectué sur l'agglomération
si on l'a fait ce parce que on y trouve
un intérêt énorme
la proximité mais également ça ne coûte
pas plus cher
je connais pas d'autres territoires qui
sont aussi efficaces
pour cela la chance que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir pratiquement
les plus grands comptes des développeurs
économiques français voire même
internationaux sur notre territoire et
nous avons également encore de la
possibilité de développement puisque
nous avons une zone qui s'appelle le sky
high tech qui est à côté de plaisir et
d'elancourt qui est un lieu en explosion
actuellement avec cette capacité
d'accueil et il ya un bureau d'études
qui travaillent sur le sujet pour
pouvoir justement fait revenir et
aspirer encore des grands comptes pour
développer tout ça nous avons des pôles
industriels commerciaux petites
entreprises puissant on est aujourd'hui
pratiquement l'intercommunalité ou
l'agglomération plutôt qui est la plus
forte en innovations et en puissance du
développement économique nous avons
encore la chance d'avoir du foncier et
les mobilités et les routes qui
desservent notre territoire
eh bien nous permettent aujourd'hui
d'avoir ce potentiel là l'investissement
de l'agglomération dans la formation des
métiers de demain est une autre réponse
aux besoins des entreprises
on met un grand coup d'accélérateur
également sur tout ce qui est employé
habilité numérique
on sent bien que c'est cette
transformation dans tous les grands
secteurs le numérique en veille tous les
métiers une accélération hors norme
l'école du numérique lancée en 2018 par
le territoire sera bientôt secondés par
un pool de cybersécurité actuellement à
l'étude mais l'attractivité ce n'est pas
seulement l'emploi
super parce que vous avez toutes les
commodités pour y vivre pour élever les
enfants
ça doit rester comme celle puisque c'est
un petit endroit lui un petit peu de
nature et après si on fait trop de
constructions ça va transformer 50 ans
sévère on est près de la forêt le reste
parisien puisque j'aime la vie
parisienne
un petit peu de clubs plus de clubs et
de barres pour ramener un puisque la
population jeune parisienne des
transports en commun sauf facile
aussi tous les accès possible pour tout
ce qui est culturel social et pourquoi
ils professionnels aussi tout était bien
pour venir y vivre
on sent le stress en moins le vrai
stress parisien où on est tout le monde
est pressé
on le ressent moins ici
[Musique]
les gens viennent de l'extérieur pour
travailler sur notre territoire mais
notre territoire à quelques difficultés
à maintenir chez nous je dirais alors
les familles s'installent puisqu'au
niveau des services on est plutôt bien
doté mais il ya toute une tranche de la
population qui sont par exemple les
jeunes cadres qui ont du mal à rester
ici parce qu'ils considèrent que ce sont
les villes dortoirs et que nous
n'apportons pas encore quelque chose
d'optimum dans leur plaisir de vivre et
de rester ici
[Musique]
pour ce faire l'agglomération souhaite
améliorer le cadre de vie et la mobilité
et répondre aux besoins d'environnement
de plus en plus exigée par les
populations
je suis de saint germain en laye
j'estime que ici c'est bien desservi
mais d'où nous venons pour venir ici mon
propre véhicule
winnie votera oui ça va ça prend un peu
de temps mais ça va oui entre les bus
les trains
les autoroutes oui ça reste facile
d'accès la mobilité un axe maintes fois
réajuster afin de répondre aux besoins
des entreprises et des populations le
plan local de déplacement a permis le
doublement du pont qui schuller à
maurepas
afin de fluidifier la circulation
d'autres grands travaux sont à venir
comme l'enfouissement de la rn10 à
trappes et la rénovation du pont de la
villedieu
côté transports en commun des tcsp ont
été aménagés l'épaule gars se sont
déployés ceci pour inciter les habitants
à délaisser leur voiture
certaines gares comme plaisir grignon et
villepreux les clés seront aussi
réaménagé dans les prochains mois les
réseaux de bus ont récemment été repensé
et plus de lignes de meilleure rotation
aux heures de pointe et le week end pour
un service optimisé ses prochaines
années saint quentin en yvelines mais
cependant serein transports en commun
innovants les navettes suspendu conçu
par la start up the prize
ces navettes seront autonomes sans
conducteur elles fonctionneront à
l'énergie solaire 24 heures sur 24 et
sept jours sur sept autres mobilité qui
s'impose à saint quentin en yvelines
la bicyclette 400 km d'itinéraires
cyclables dont 150 dédié au vélo vélo
perso ou bien loué à la vélostation de
la gare de saint-quentin vélo électrique
ou classique la mobilité douce a trouvé
sa voie sur le territoire un nouveau
schéma de pistes cyclables est
actuellement à l'étude celui ci devrait
s'étendre aux douze communes
cette mobilité avec peut-être cette
nouvelle circulation aérienne que nous
sommes en train de réfléchir va nous
permettre d'avoir un développement
extraordinaire et un développement
durable pour répondre aux exigences des
populations alors l'écologie est un
point oui
un moment important on essaye de mettre
en place des choses en tout cas moi dans
l'entreprise dans laquelle je travaille
forcément l'écologie c'est au quotidien
je pense que dans le 78 on est plutôt
privilégié on a encore à cette forêt où
ils espaces verts je pense qu'ils ont
fait un bon travail donc c'est bien de
courage et de continuer j'aime bien me
balader où il ya 50 ans c'est une ville
certes ville nouvelle mais qui quand on
va à côté à côté de la fac et c'est
assez sympa je trouve qu'ils restent
dans l'esprit fin de de préserver cet
environnement des espaces verts on a la
chance d'être dans dans la vallée au
bord de la vallée de chevreuse mais
franchement je trouve ça vraiment très
très agréable saint-quentin-en-yvelines
possède 60% des espaces naturels des
espaces aquatiques boisés ou encore des
chants et des étendues d'herbe 5000
hectares de surfaces végétalisée 38
bassin de stockage 78 mille arbres
forêts et jardins privés intercepte 2000
tonnes de particules chaque année et 70
mille tonnes de co2 par an
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié du
territoire saint quentinois est composée
d' espaces verts autant d'éléments
naturels qui lutte contre le changement
climatique grand froid comme fortes
chaleurs mais on s'est rendu compte avec
le diagnostic du projet territoire qu'il
était fondamental de recréer des lieux
de vie et des lieux justement qui
répondent aujourd'hui à ses attentes qui
sont et bien la biodiversité le maintien
des espaces verts les maintien des
espaces naturels
l'amélioration de tous les forestiers et
agricoles
donc on a un vrai potentiel qu'il faut
non seulement redécouvrir les valoriser
et mettre à disposition de la population
protéger les espaces naturels préservés
la qualité paysagère ou encore limiter
l'impact énergétique des bâtiments faire
des énergies renouvelables et de
récupération une priorité réduire les
pollutions et leur effet grâce à des
solutions innovantes telle est la
feuille de route du projet ce qui demain
pour les années à venir
on est déjà en train d'étudier le
potentiel de chaque collectivité puisque
chaque collectivité a la chance d'être
parti d'un petit village pour la plupart
et puis d'avoir au sein de ce village
est bien des zones qui sont des zones
vertes et puis aussi avec des
transversales et des circulations bleus
on pense véritablement que je dirais
dans dans quelques années on ne nous
regardera plus uniquement comme un lieu
uniquement urbain mais un lieu vers
parce que nous avons ce grand potentiel
un potentiel que souhaite demain mettre
en exergue le territoire à travers ces
projets des douze communes
il s'agit de faire en sorte que les
habitants se réapproprient nous re
découvre cette richesse si surtout une
reconnaissance de lait coûte que nous
avons eues avec les saint quentinois
parce que les axes viennent de ce que
nous avons récolté nous utilisons la
matière que nous ont donné les
saint-quentinois pour un bout c
ce qui m'agace c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui à très bientôt pour de
nouvelles aventures saint-quentinoise
ciao
[Musique]